so we had the first presidential debate
this week there are still two more
debates
uh next week is the vp debate but then
the week after and the week after that
we have debates number
two and three between donald trump and
joe biden and it turns out that donald
trump
so ruined the prospects of having an
actual debate on tuesday night
because of his constant petulant
interruptions that the commission on
presidential debates
is changing the rules for the debates in
order to allow
an actual adult conversation it's just
stunning they have to
account for donald trump's childish
behavior something which you know it's
much like
the norms that we have established for
presidential conduct
many of them we don't think about what
happens if we have to enforce them
because we imagine we would never have
to
much like that with the debate rules
they now are having to come up with
rules
because donald trump goes above and
beyond what is normal and the commission
on presidential debates has now said
quote
last night's debate made clear that
additional structure
should be added to the format of the
remaining debates to ensure a more
orderly discussion of the issues
the commission will be carefully
considering the changes
that it will adopt and we'll announce
those measures shortly now those
measures have not yet been announced
there's a source close to the commission
which says they are thinking about
giving the moderator or someone
the ability to cut off silence or mute a
candidate's microphone when they violate
rules like for example when joe biden
was
speaking during his two minutes donald
trump would just keep talking and
talking and talking
the the issue with that as far as we've
been told
is both candidates would need to agree
to it in principle
i can't imagine trump would agree to it
now the commission could always say
the situation is extenuating and we're
putting this this rule in place even if
you don't agree
and then it would be up to trump to
either bail on the debate or or
to go but i i assume that
there's not too many other tools you can
really think about putting in place
and the reaction from trump campaign
communications director
tim murdoch is to disagree and
he put out a written statement saying
quote they shouldn't be moving the goal
posts and changing the rules in the
middle of the game
moderator chris wallace has been
criticized as if he were the problem
i think you know he did a reasonably
okay job given the tools that he had
but chris wallace says he doesn't think
muting the microphones would really
solve the problem he said that quote
even if the president's microphone had
been shut he still could have continued
to interrupt
and biden's microphone might have picked
it up anyway
i i do think that although that's true
if you mute trump's mic and biden is
talking and you hear
trump in the background much more
quietly
that just makes trump look even worse
and and
although chris wallace is right in a
sense i think that that would have been
very very bad if biden is talking and
the camera's on biden
but you sort of hear trump tweeting like
a little bird in the background now
trump's perspective on all of this is
less nuanced less sophisticated
uh donald trump tweeted quote try
getting a new anchor and a smarter
democrat
candidate they just can't play by the
rules trump can't
his family can't they don't play by the
rules in any aspect of their lives and
they're not playing by the rules here
speaking of rules by the way you might
have seen video of when trump's family
entered the debate hall
melania ivanka etc they were wearing
masks as were the rules of the
the debate hall but then they just took
them off when the debate got started
and uh you know that that's against the
rules they just sat there maskless
everybody else was wearing masks
okay i mean i i they just don't follow
the rules and there are no repercussions
now the idea i have for this is sort of
a difficult to manage
idea because it's logistically difficult
but my idea would be
if it's biden's time and trump starts
talking over him
you pause biden's time so he doesn't
lose any time
while while trump is interrupting and
trump's interruptions are deducted from
his next answer so
if trump interrupts for 20 seconds biden
gets an
extra 20 seconds and in his next answer
trump loses 20 seconds
it's very hard to manage in real time
trump would absolutely lose his
mind they would cry about fake news
everybody's against them all of this
stuff
but that's really the only idea i can
think of which is
if you can't stop trump from talking but
you can say
we have a total amount of speaking time
here and any that you use now you don't
get to use later
it's an idea if you have a better one
certainly let me know
now if you want something approximating
substantive discussion here
i believe the only real chance at that
is the vice presidential debate next
week
vice presidential nominee kamala harris
will be facing off
wednesday evening against vice president
mike pence
i believe she's going to crush him i
think it's going to be
just a brutal brutal slaughtering of
mike pence by kamal harris
but let's watch it together we will be
streaming wednesday evening
live on youtube twitch and facebook
i invite you to join me i think it will
be very interesting and maybe we will
actually get
some policy discussion which would be
interesting for a change
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes
or save with a subscription it's the
year 2020.
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer
i'm required to give these products
contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical